The Season 5 finale of Game Of Thrones was
cliff-hanger central, leaving just about every
major plotline up in the air.
So, what I'm going to do is talk about where
things could be headed in Season 6.
This video is going to be all about the big
event, "For The Watch", and what that means
for the future of Jon Snow and the Night's
Watch.
Just to give you a heads-up, there's going
to be speculation and possible spoilers for
the show and the books in this video!
Just before we start, in memory of Jon Snow,
our friends at Fun.com have given us a fantastic
Funko POP Vinyl figure to give away to awesome
viewers!
All you need to do is be a subscriber and
leave a comment about Jon Snow or the Night's
Watch on this video.
Jon Snow got Julius Caesar-ed, and he didn't
even see it coming!
He may have realised he was the 'most hated
man in Castle Black' but he still let Samwell
Tarly leave him friendless, apart from Dolorous
Edd at the Wall.
In the end, Jon Snow really did know nothing
– if he'd had any sense he'd have been using
the giant Wun Wun or Tormund the Wildling
as a bodyguard.
There was loads of foreshadowing throughout
the season for who was going to stab Jon Snow:
all those glares from Olly and Jon deciding
to keep his enemy Alliser Thorne near rather
than send him off and Bowen Marsh appeared
as well!
Oh, and by the way, it was interesting that
Alliser Thorne stabbed Jon 'For The Watch'
as when Ser Alliser was leading the Watch
during the battle of Castle Black in Season
4 he told Jon that "leadership means being
second-guessed by twats".
Well, it seems like Ser Alliser's been doing
quite a lot of his own second-guessing this
season about Jon's decision to work with the
Wildlings to save the Watch and everyone else
from the White Walkers.
I wonder how long he and the Night's Watch
will live to regret that fact next season?!
The way For The Watch happened reminded me
of Janos Slynt's beheading…
Jon hesitated at first but then Jon's face
screwed up when Slynt said how afraid he was,
and Jon beheaded him.
Olly was also hesitant at first, but when
Jon said Olly's name, the young boy also screwed
up his face & stabbed Jon hard.
There were also shades of Red Wedding about
Jon's death, which was similar to Robb Stark's
end.
Probably not a coincidence given this episode
was directed by David Nutter, who also directed
The Red Wedding episode.
On a side note, the way Arya killed Meryn
Trant also reminded me of how Catelyn Stark
killed Walder Frey's wife and how she was
ultimately killed herself, with a slit to
the throat.
Jon's death also made me think of Ned Stark's
death, especially because of the constant
parallels that have been drawn between Jon
and Ned this season.
For example, Stannis told Jon that 'you're
as stubborn and honourable as your father.'
Jon replied, 'I can imagine no higher praise.'
To which Stannis said, 'I didn't mean it as
praise.
Honour got your father killed.'
Straight after the season 5 finale Entertainment
Weekly released an interview with Kit Harington
who plays Jon Snow.
In it they asked him "Is Jon really dead?"
Now he replied "This is my understanding of
it."
He also said "If anything in the future is
not like that, then I don't know about it
– it's only in David and Dan and George's
heads."
And he added "I'm not coming back next season
and I'm looking for movies for next year."
That's fine, it doesn't mean his character's
out of the show forever, because as we know
they skipped storylines and seasons for Isaac
Hempstead-Wright as Bran and everyone else
in that storyline wasn't in season 5 but they
will be returning for season 6.
Of course, he could still be filming for season
6, but given all the leaks during films, it'd
be really difficult to keep his return under
wraps if he is filming at any point this year
for Season 6.
Maybe he won't be in Season 6 a lot and he's
shot some stuff already.
Also another little thing from the interview
that made me think he's returning is he didn't
get a parting gift, like Rose Leslie, who
played Ygritte did.
Wouldn't be the first time an actor had to
be creative with the truth to avoid spoiling
major plot points in an interview.
Still, there are ways that Jon Snow could
return and fulfil Samwell Tarly's words that
"I've been worrying about Jon for years; he
always comes back."
First of all, the Red Woman, Melisandre, has
returned to Castle Black.
In fact, in the books, she never left.
And, like Thoros of Myr did with Beric Dondarrion,
it's possible that she could bring Jon Snow
back to life with the power of the Lord of
Light.
Now, when someone's brought back to life there
are side effects for example a person loses
some of their memories and is less themselves,
as Beric Dondarrion told Arya in Season 3.
So, maybe Jon Snow won't be exactly the Jon
Snow we know, in other words, he'll be "someone
else…
something else", like Oliver Queen in Arrow!
And the fact that Jon is stabbed beside a
cross adds to the vibe that he's going to
have a Christ-like resurrection.
Another possibility is that Jon wargs into
Ghost.
Now, in the TV show, we didn't see Jon's direwolf
at the end of the episode when he's attacked.
However, in the books, as Jon is stabbed by
his fellow Night's Watchmen he says the word
"Ghost".
But remember episode 7 this season, when some
Night's Watch men attacked Gilly and taunted
Sam by saying, "Your friend Jon Snow's not
here now".
And who appeared right at that moment?
Yes, it was Ghost.
So, both the show and the book seem to be
hinting that Jon Snow might warg into Ghost.
and, during a Q&A event at Oxford University,
Kit Harington said that he'd like to be a
warg and 'put himself into a wolf'!
To which, Dan Weiss replied, 'Two words for
you: Season 6.'
And there's another possibility…
Remember when we saw the White Walkers and
the Night's King during the Hardhome episode?
Well, there was a definite Night's Watch vibe
to their clothing worn.
Dressing the White Walkers like Men in Black
in the show is likely a nod to book readers
that the Night's King in the series is also
a former Lord Commander of the Night's Watch!
All of which makes me wonder if the fact that
one of the Wildlings called Jon "King Crow"
means that something more is going to happen
between Jon and the Night's King?
And there was also that long lingering look
between the Night's King and Jon Snow, just
before the chief Iceman raised his arms and
with them his horde of new wildling wights!
Was it just one former Lord Commander, the
Night's King, observing the new Lord Commander
Jon Snow?
Or could it be that the Night's King isn't
just a former Lord Commander, but Jon's long-lost
uncle and fellow Night's Watchman, Benjen
Stark?
And, could Jon be reanimated to the Night's
King's band of walkers and wights?
But what if Jon Snow were actually, horror
of horrors, dead?!
Well, then he'd just be the latest in a long
line of Starks to kick the bucket in nasty,
treacherous circumstances.
And I mean it's not like Game Of Thrones hasn't
killed off big characters in the past.
So, have all the apparent foreshadowing for
Jon's come-back in the show just been red
herrings?
It's entirely possible.
After all, there have been others, and everyone
from Kit Harington to John Bradley, the episode's
director David Nutter and the showrunners
are doing interviews saying that John is dead!
And the official HBO viewer guide says that
Olly "conspired with other brothers to murder
[Jon Snow], and delivered the fatal cut."
So, are we just in denial?
Say it ain't so!!
Of course, just like they skipped Bran's storyline
this season, there's always a chance they
leave the Watch and the Wall until season
7.
Samwell and Gilly are on their way to Old
Town where he wants to become a Maester, like
Maester Aemon, who died this season.
Samwell's already killed a White Walker with
dragonglass.
And the show seems to be foreshadowing Sam's
future importance again in the battle against
the White Walkers as Samwell told Jon that
at the citadel's library he'd be able to "learn
about history, strategy, healing, and other
things, things that'll help when they come."
So, will Sam discover a treasure trove of
dragonglass or Valyrian steel from his readings
at the Citadel?
So, those are my thoughts on what might happen
for Jon Snow in Season 6.
Do you think Jon's really dead?
If not, how would you like him to return?
Don't forget, for a chance to win a Funko
POP Vinyl figure, subscribe and leave a comment
about Jon Snow.
Congratulations to "Spartain14" for winning
our last competition!
I'll send you a message shortly to get your
details.
By the way, if you haven't seen it yet, I
spoke to Brenock O'Connor who plays Olly,
who betrayed Jon Snow, and he's got some really
interesting stuff to say!
Click here to watch that!
And I'll have more Season 6 prediction videos
coming up!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
And remember, if you're not watching Jan G
on GoT, you know nothing!